the biggest mistake is over reliance on
dialogue they remember their favorite
lines from movies and come into the
enterprise thinking that it's about
writing lines of dialogue for the actors
when in fact it's really about the
structure it's about setting up the
visual scenes it's about putting the
scenes together in what order actually
tells the story and really taking
advantage of the visual medium and the
dialogue are often you know comes after
that it's it's mmm if you the beginning
writer will rely very heavily on
dialogue to give you all the information
you need so characters are constantly
telling each other things i think this i
intend that i like that where it's much
better to find a visual way to get that
idea across it's more elegant and it's
more filming and it's very very
obviously amateurish to a an experienced
writer to look at a screenplay that is
all reliant on dialogue
in my experience I've spent a lot of
time and development on various projects
and uh I've seen screenplays get worse
I've seen them get better and um it's
the structure is the thing that usually
has to change and when you change the
structure you wind up having to change
everything else too because what would
happen in a scene changes so the
dialogue changes everything does
sometimes it winds towards the juicy
center and the notes you're getting or
helping it become the screenplay it
needs to become but there's that at some
point where it becomes like a Hail Mary
and it just has become very difficult
and messed up and mixed up themes and
and different people's stories and you
wind up with everybody looking at it
it's not just you anymore it's you in a
room full of people and everybody has a
different opinion and sometimes they
just say well try this because they just
don't know and then you realize that the
project is gone it's it's somehow gotten
away from everybody and that's not
unusual and it's not too hard for that
to happen and it's not really the fault
of anybody i found that development
executives and producers are actually
very smart and although there have been
some many many stupid and clueless and
difficult and impossible notes i've
gotten that i had to somehow solve more
often the notes are quite good and make
a lot of sense and have been helpful
I no no i don't know that i can think of
anything you know quit uh give up